If you're shocked at the price of meat when you go grocery shopping,
consider this a solution to your problems.
After much deliberation,
we decided to finally add rabbits to our homestead.
And here's why. We currently raise pasture raised chicken
and it is not a sustainable option.
Although we love raising chickens,
you have to continuously buy this cross breed that makes good meat
birds from hatcheries. So it's not something that you can do yourself.
So not sustainable. And it's a really easy to breed.
You can multiply the amount of rabbits you have
in a pretty short space of time.
And if you're used to raising livestock,
they are pretty easy to look after.
Now we already have a source of dairy on our farm,
so I really would like a continuous source of meat
that I don't have to outsource from our farm.
Now rabbit is really easy to cook.
There's plenty of recipes out there.
Here I'm trying a French mustard sauce rabbit and it is really good.
We are not used to eating rabbit that much in the west,
but I am from England and in a few generations back,
rabbit was a totally normal thing to eat on a weekly basis,
although
I wasn't really wanting to have something cute and fluffy to eat.
Now I've processed them myself
and I've used their drop ins in the garden.
I can really see the benefit of having them,
how they're very sustainable
and how They're a good fit for anybody
who's wanting to produce their own food.